question combien va venir avec toi ce
qui se passe dans un petit peu et dans
la tue c'est vrai qu'il ya soir hier on
a appris la disparition de jean paul
belmondo je sais que tu lui a rendu
hommage sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment c'est bien sûr un événement
qui a touché des millions tient un choc
énorme il en a vraiment le sentiment que
si faisait partie de notre famille il
était
extraordinairement sympa très talentueux
mais ses commandes il ya ce sont des
stars comme il n'en existe plus du tout
parce qu'il dit il était à la fois très
très un des treize sincère avec le
public et en même temps une immense sein
c'est un mélange des deux tu vois que tu
es complètement de l'amour et est
vraiment c'est moi je ne sais pas paru
sur mon truc j'ai été catastrophé c'est
un homme qu'on aime beaucoup que j'ai
beaucoup aimé les ondes avec 8 non j'ai
pas tourné le temps et qui s'ils n'ont
6,6 sur des coups à prendre avec lui on
n'a jamais tant des cuisses et même
temps les mêmes sur un plateau je vous
n'êtes jamais retrouver ensemble non je
l'avais fois que je l'aï vu c'était il
ya je crois il ya deux ans dans un
restaurant dans le septième match aller
le voir bien sûr je voyais aussi en
corse quand j'étais encore ce que cet
homme même quand il était après son avc
et d'été un disque il est radié est une
chose absolument unique c'est ça c'est
vraiment c'est bien de lui rendre
hommage et c'est bien de l'ebbe quoi
comme comme comme on les aime et comme
on aimait les acteurs mais je crois
surtout que si tu veux c'est quelqu'un
qui reste et qui donnait pas du tout de
leçons et qui faisait son métier
génialement il a très très bien c'est un
acteur de théâtre au départ ce quelqu'un
qui formeraient ne portent pas si le
consommateur est à la comédie-française
et après bien la star qu'on connaît
alors la nouvelle vague l'aide parce que
il as eu ton différent du doigt et puis
après il devient un grand acteur
la critique aura dit il était commercial
mais en fait c'est un acteur populaire
simplement ils volaient des salles
pleines tu regrettes ne pas avoir joué
avec lui ou pas car énormément jamais tu
t'es dit je vais peut-être écrire un
truc pour nous deux ou un moment dont je
regrette il y en a deux que quelqu'un je
regrette beaucoup de pas avoir tourné
c'est lui et lino ventura et lino on
avait vraiment écrire un script pour lui
une pub de finale ceux ci ne réglaient
proposé papilles et il est mort qu'un
bon voilà écoute c'est comme ça qu'il a
fait de la résistance
incroyable non mais c'est vrai que c'est
galabru cas l'an passé séguéla bouaké
remplacé à huy et il y aura un hommage
national jean-paul aux invalides ce sera
jeudi c'est normal qu'ils aient bien sûr
c'est samba ou ici alors ça serait
l'europe si tu veux c'est très bien je
trouve pas ce que la ville le mérite pro
fondation voilà et j'espère que ce sera
un hommage pour le cinéma à 9 h pour le
cinéma populaire pour ce qui était cet
homme ait pas trop de récupération
politique en vue d'une prochaine
élection emmanuel macron présidera la
cérémonie si vous avez des infos bernard
montiel oui je crois qu'il sera avec lui
non mais et avec lui parce qu'ils
l'aident beaucoup
il connaît pas moins été pris cette
décision comment prend 7 d'ici donc
d'abord c'est avec l'accord de la
famille donc c'est la famille qui décide
évidemment avec en consultation de
l'elysée pour savoir ce qu'on fait ce
que les invalides célestin est bien un
sujet un canton qui il se trouve qu'elle
est là pour ça je trouve que l'elysée
est allée à la rencontre des bêlements
d'eau cet après midi dont une très
grande réunion chez pol et luan à cet
après-midi et notamment madame macron j
étais et c'était ils ont décidé tous
ensemble voilà et a priori pas priori
non c'est elle qu'il a b c d
et es donc d'après l'article
ce serait plutôt vers 16h demain après
midi mais ce n'est pas encore sûr ça de
mettre le matin jeudi sera jeudi ce sera
jeudi c'est sur wii dont il a redit
voilà quand vous êtes au niveau des
jours de la semaine
je crois que gens voudront gay ou pas
une question comme ça simplement
manifestement oui quoi
oui juste vous avez dit reçu christian
cadier non jamais non il ya des missions
lui
[Applaudissements]
sur l 13 6 ans je fais des émissions de
télé de radio
je suis moi je suis passé à côté je suis
pas du tout du tout le monde
connaît pas
c'est certainement une erreur oui oui il
est sur l afem tous ses heures et oui
tous ses amis qu'elle
[Rires]
s'était en fait il m'a jamais 1,8 c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui j'ai reçu jugnot
c'est un grand ancien
et profond jamais christian pas ça c'est
pas trop et comme ça il n'a jamais voulu
jamais voulu mais parce qu'il reçoit
beaucoup d'en faire c'est
ce que je reçois que sa
septième balasko je rêvais non mais on a
bien compris
[Applaudissements]
si je serais très honoré de recevoir 8
résonnerait c'est pour ça que je n'irai
pas
alors vous avez vu que tout le monde a
rendu hommage à jean paul belmondo bien
entendu et il ya même la représentante
des verts et que l'hiver maintenant
gendrel rousseau
alors j'ai rien contre elle parce
qu'elle est plutôt sympathique en plus
henry reçoit un nom catastrophe l ami
quand même jean-pierre belmondo quoi il
implique elle aurait pu dire jean
bernard regarder merci jean pierre
belmondo a déjà déjà le tweet démarre
mal quoi tunnel à côté de la plaque et
le
même pas toujours les dernières cascades
en espérant qu'elle n'ait pas été
difficile
ça c'est ce que je pense que c'est elle
partait d'une bonne intention mais quand
on a pas d'humour mais ce sont des gens
qui rient candice brûle
évidemment c'est un humour de yens donc
évidemment c'est catastrophique
après je vous dire allez pas méchant
away est plutôt sympa ça se discute un
an nettement pourquoi attention moi je
trouve qu'elle a tous font partout tout
le temps comme on la connaît pas aux
jeux par exemple jean-pierre ça peut
être le téléphone des fois tu vois jean
pierre défaut de l'iphone il ya des fois
nous fait même pas attention
avec josiane balasko et je crois pas ils
étaient tous les trois du même avis
et je vous dirai pas paul belmondo moi
je me disais ça va ya voir hier un
hommage aux invalidités pour la
maintenance et pour jean paul belmondo
c'est logique celle aussi où on est
d'accord alors je vous le dis il n'y a
jamais eu autant de déprogrammation à la
télé absolument que pour johnny hallyday
c'est à dire que c'est voilà c'est
johnny et jean paul belmondo joué le
même nombre de déprogrammation c'est à
dire que toutes les chaînes
vraiment
aimé croissance est méritée et je vous
dis depuis johnny notamment nous lie à
jamais eu autant des programmations la
télé n'a jamais eu autant d'hommages et
il faut dire aussi que de tous ces
grands patrons de chaînes sont
conseillés par bernard montiel
beaucoup de gens mais c'est un gars qui
te parle à l'oreille des jeux
j'espère de gym cricket
sur ton épaule et qui te dis
comme ça ne le fait pas comme ça ça
c'est fort